we've been testing the s24 ultra for a
couple of days now and it's pretty clear
that it's the best Android phone that
you can buy right now by far with a new
design that features a flat display in
back with very thin bezels on the front
new camera updates and impressive chip
performance but I've got to admit
there's one important thing missing
which is builtin ch2 magnets to support
Mac safe accessories like we've had on
the iPhone for years and that's
precisely where this comes in which is
the oand case from our Channel sponsor
tourists who make phones truly Ultra
because tourist products redefine
durability with quality that lasts it's
not just about buying more it's about
using better the ostan case is part of a
set of tourist accessories that I'm
going to walk you through in this video
including this very unique magnetic
power bank that you're not going to want
to miss but starting off with the oan
case this is hands down the best case
you can buy because it's basically a
regular phone case plus a stand plus Max
saafe magnets plus a ring all together
all in one product giving you incredible
value just think about it if you were to
buy a protective case that protects your
edges and display like this one does
with magnets built in then you would buy
a stand accessory then you would buy a
magnet magnetic ring accessory you'd be
spending a lot of cash compared to just
buying the Taurus oan case which has all
of that in one for just $32 on Amazon on
sale right now the stand aspect is
really impressive because you can easily
unfold it and set your phone up in
vertical or portrait mode which is great
for let's say taking selfie photos or
watching videos like Tik toks and
YouTube shorts or simply having it stand
and swiping through Twitter or whatever
else and then you can also stand your
phone up on its side to watch YouTube
videos movies shows whatever you'd like
another useful feature is for the ring
itself so you can use it as a finger
grip which is pretty handy on very large
phones like the s24 ultra especially for
people with smaller hands who have a
hard time handling a phone like this and
the best part is that when you fold the
stand back down it sits literally flush
with the case and it doesn't stick out
which means that you can use it with Max
safe accessories like my Max saafe
wallet just like this as well as other
Max safe accessories like the wireless
charging puck or even portable battery
Banks like the one from Taurus and of
course it'll also stick to Magnetic
surfaces and as far as the case itself
it's got military grade drop protection
with raised edges to protect protect the
camera bumps as well as the sides and
the front display while not becoming way
too bulky like other cases it's still
nice and slim they got many color
options to choose from like this matte
black and a clear case but on top of
these oand cases they also have a couple
of other cool case options right here
both including the built in magnets
which I'd argue is a must for a case in
2024 I literally won't use a case that
doesn't have Magnus built in first off
there's their Pand case which has a more
traditional kickstand built into the
bottom like this instead of the ring if
you prefer that style instead and of
course you can prop it up in both
vertical and horizontal modes this one
is just 30 bucks on Amazon on sale right
now and then finally they have their
Guardian MA case which is the simplest
out of the bunch giving you an option if
you prefer not to have have a kickstand
built in at all with a clean and simple
set of magnets built into the case while
offering excellent protection and it's
just 24 bucks on Amazon which is also a
great deal and for this case or actually
any of the cases that I just mentioned
comes the perfect combination that you
need to try with your s24 Ultra which is
the oand portable power bank which is
probably the slimmest and lightest power
bank I've ever seen being basically half
the thickness of a standard power bank
at only 11.6 mm thick and it's basically
lighter than an apple and the best part
is that it comes with an oand ring built
in and it actually spins around so you
don't have to sacrifice the convenience
of a stand while using the power bank
it's simply always there on the back and
of course it works in both vertical and
Landscape orientations and because of
the slim profile and the lightweight
it's super convenient to just throw it
into your pocket and whenever you need a
quick charge on your phone pull it out
and snap it right onto your Taurus case
and just like that the wireless charging
coils are perfectly aligned and charging
your phone while barely adding any
weight so you can easily slip it back
into your pocket while charging with the
portable battery pack it's JM packed
with 5,000 milliamp hours of battery
power which literally matches the same
amount as what's in the s24 ultra itself
and another cool feature is that it
comes with a USBC port on the bottom for
recharging or you can actually grab a
cable plug it in and charge a different
device using that cable which is very
handy and for all of that built in it's
just 60 bucks on Amazon on sale which is
a great price compared to the
competition now one thing you can't
forget if you're going to be buying an
s24 ultra or any other phone is a screen
protector Taurus has their Diamond
Shield screen protector which is the
perfect addition on top of getting a tus
case for ultimate trustworthy protection
of your new phone and the best part of
this one is that unlike other screen
protectors it comes with a very simple
and easy three-step installation process
and it also comes with an extra spare in
the Box to share with your friend after
you clean your display all you do is
place the Box on top of the phone press
down and pull on the little tab on the
bottom and within moments the screen
protector adheres evenly and in most
cases you won't even need the handy
dandy little tool they include in the
Box for getting rid of air bubbles and
just like that your screen is protected
and it looks great with they perfectly
even fit every time it's got solid
protection with all-around coverage and
9h hardness using Aerospace materials
and nanoscale pressure and resilience
there's absolutely no color deviation so
you get 100% of the original displays
color reproduction and it gives you high
touch sensitivity with Spen support
working just as you'd expect it to and
it's only 26 bucks on Amazon on sale
right now for a two pack so finally to
give you guys a quick summary of these
tourist products we've got the O case
we've got the PST case and and the
guardian mag case all with mag safe
magnets built in we of course have the
super slim oand portable power bank and
we have the diamond Shield screen
protector as well and you can find the
links to all of these musthave Taurus
s24 ultra accessories down in the
description and pan comment below once
again thanks to taus for sponsoring this
video and be sure to subscribe for more
videos like this one by clicking that
button above thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
go